the the quarterback position will come
into focus now in denver where george
payton long-time
vikings executive most recently
assistant general manager is the new gm
he had been with minnesota since 2007.
um
look i know broncos fans are really
happy about this development but but
while we're
on the topic of quarterbacks
peyton was with the vikings from 2007
through
2020 and
other than brett favre have fallen into
their laps it hasn't exactly been a
murderer's row at quarterback for the
vikings and look
you never know and this is a point
shireen williams made last night on
pftpm
when you hire a gm you never really know
what the guy
did in his prior jobs he was part of a
broader
structure maybe he was the weak link i
don't know
who's he advocating on draft day is he
advocating guys that they're picking
and are great is he advocating guys who
they're picking and aren't great
is he advocating guys they didn't pick
who ended up being great somewhere else
i don't know how much of that you can
ever reconstruct after the fact
unless someone is there taking copious
notes every step of the way well let's
see rick spielman
rick spielman liked kirk cousins and
george payton said we should go
draft baker mayfield
they wouldn't have gotten mayfield but
you get my point i got you but but
i i'm saying all this because
quarterback is such a critical
position yeah for the denver broncos
right now absolutely critical
they just moved on by giving him a
promotion
by all appearances even though it's not
from a hall of fame quarterback who
couldn't
find a quarterback other than when
peyton manning fell into his lap and i
know that everybody wanted him and look
having a
hall of fame quarterback gm made it
easier to speak the same language and
get peyton manning
but but here's my point minnesota
vikings 2007
through the present have had a hard time
finding
great quarterbacks before that peyton
was the director of pro personnel with
the dolphins from 2001 through 2006 in
the early years of the revolving door of
crap
post dan marino now he's director of pro
personnel
doesn't mean he's making the decisions
but he's in the trust tree
of this this front office that's that's
groping to find a decent quarterback
and then before that he was with the
bears when they drafted kade mcdown who
exactly so i i just all i'm saying about
any of this because i think george
payton's going to be great
but don't assume he's just gonna walk
through the door and have the answer at
quarterback
because the vikings haven't had the
answer at quarterback since the one year
that brett favre
was good with them yeah well okay i know
you've had some good there i mean kirk
cousins is not a slouch
let's not go crazy on that he was the
quarterback of your like top five
offense in football this year
and you know can make plays i know he's
not a superstar but it's still a pretty
damn good quarterback
okay now the rest of the you're right
it's real it's not that easy to evaluate
these guys and get the right guy all the
time and i think you said it too
you know he's not in charge of making
those final decisions a lot of the time
so we don't know where they are
we know where he was who knows maybe he
liked some guys that we
turned out to be stars but you're like
you said somebody above him didn't like
see it that way and they went another
direction but
it is a real conversation with the
denver broncos i don't think he has to
worry about it
per se like this year i do think drew
locke did enough to earn the right to
come back next year
and see if he's the guy but it's got to
be on your radar to think
okay drew drew lock we go through
halfway through the year and we see
whoa he's not the guy it's too many
interceptions it's just too raw
then yeah they're gonna have to start
looking at college kids and start
going down that you know avenue once
again to drafting a quarterback
or finding their next peyton manning and
having just another free agent
proven guy come in there you know we'll
say it's going to be a big year this
will be it for drew luck i think drew
locke of course he
he's going to have a chance to be the
starter but i would think that
they bring in a pretty high level backup
this year
for insurance or a drew lock vic vangio
this is a huge year for him
he can't like have a team that's pretty
damn good
and have some young quarterbacks
screwing it all up and we saw dru lock
do that a little bit last year
so i think he's going to want to have a
guy there that's a little bit proven to
worry all right
pull the string we're going to play this
way you get in there i could trust you
and do that but it's a big conversation
no doubt mike
and george payton's had plenty of
opportunities over the years he's
consistently rebuffed them why did he
take this one because there's a sense
that the broncos are in a weird kind of
a spot here what's going to happen with
ownership are they going to sell the
team
the six-year deal that he signed gives
him financial protection against the
possibility of the team being sold and a
new owner saying we want a different gm
that's right and also
this john elway thing he's in the last
year of his contract
this to me and based on some things i've
heard
yeah he's he's done after this year okay
most likely
right so so if if it goes well yeah for
george payton
he becomes john elway next year they
don't hire a new vp of football
operations or president of football
operations
that it's going to be george payton
running the football operations if it
all goes well
and we'll see and i don't know what it
means for it all to go well
but not having a losing record for the
fifth straight year would
would seem to be the most basic
objective
i think for a team that hadn't had
back-to-back
losing seasons for 40-plus years
before they fell into a hole a few years
ago
they're not far off that's the one thing
i'll say i know it says 5 and 11.
but i don't know if you agree with this
now but let's not forget
no courtlin sutton this year i would say
he he was
probably the best player on their
offense they missed him von miller
not there all year long either you know
they had a few other injuries too that
hurt their football team at full
strength i look at them and
you know a few additions and the rookies
get a year older and all that i go
the broncos could be one of those teams
next year we're talking about going
didn't make the playoffs last year this
year they're right in the thick of
things and have a chance to make it i
would not be surprised if we were there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports